hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and it's John Humphrey over here so
we're gonna watch today Ryan Gosling and
Harrison Ford they lose it at hilarious
interview hilarious interview no it's
called this morning I'm excited to see
this because I love celebrities
I love celebrities laughing and if
there's one way to get me in the mood to
watch Bladerunner 2049 tomorrow
it is watching these two very serious
actors watch these characters goof
around and make me wish when I'm
watching the movie that they were having
this much fun in the film it's my hope
that they lose it in an uncomfortable
way and start yelling at each other
that's why I didn't watch life Jake
Gyllenhaal Ryan rouse are soo funny in
the interviews I know they're not gonna
be that way that's just my
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
maybe being a sequel to one of his film
maybe la la la la land
[Music]
[Laughter]
dystopian atmosphere but there is also a
[Laughter]
[Applause]
twas a delight all celebrity interviews
were like that it's just filled with joy
and laughter and you know spontaneous
standing up and crossing the point I
wasn't really catching what we were even
talking laughing you know like that
video I showed you or Bradley Cooper and
Jimmy I watch that again as recently two
visits makes you feel good I love Ryan
Gosling and Harrison Ford together you
know we watched Blade Runner again last
night again Harrison Ford especially in
that movie you know I'm sure others
pointed out I'm so glad they did how he
like is not charming and that film at
all yeah it's like there's the four star
hired and gruff yeah that's what
Harrison Ford would become in interviews
down the road and what I loved about all
these interviews at the the junkets have
done together with
gosling Harrison Ford is they seem to
just be having a great time hanging out
and I feel like everyone who works with
Ryan Gosling just loves or does it seems
like he has an infectious energy and a
very gregarious presence you know I
match to the nice guy who makes you feel
comfortable
Harrison Ford's a much he's an actor has
been around a lot longer and then last
year they were promoting Ryan Gosling
Russell Crowe promoting the nice guys
and their chemistry when they were
promoting was just fantastic you just
bear up Ryan Gosling our celebrity for
the Millennials right now with the older
actors need support like great bonds oh
yeah soon as they get Ryan Gosling on
the Expendables it's going well this is
just dark futuristic than nice guys it
makes me look forward to seeing them on
camera together because when you watch
not laughing at all when I watched Blade
Runner it's so apparent to me why Ryan
Gosling was chosen he's not taking over
for Deckard but I'm sure it's gonna fill
in the shoes of an actor who does a lot
of staring a lot of looking oh he's
gonna Shia LaBeouf this Crystal Skull
and Ryan Gosling's that actor nowadays
who I find more compelling when he's
just staring more than when I watch
Harrison Ford doing a lot of staring
Gosling has that and I do feel that Ryan
Gosling and Harrison Ford when I see
Harris in front like I could see in a
lot of ways how Ryan Gosling
he's totally his own person but he has
aspects that are reminiscent of a
younger Harrison Ford yeah certain
aspects they're very different in
personality that's the other thing about
this interview that I love - Harrison
Ford really cracks up at the
interviewers comments yeah Ryan Gosling
has makes him laugh a lot he's really
good at keeping a deadpan face what
would the interviewers it usually seems
like he doesn't care to be doing the
interviews this time around I look like
Harrison Ford with found her genuinely
funny yeah it looks like they all were
happy to sort of associate Harrison Ford
with being a grumpy bowl of oatmeal yeah
that's just what he reminds me of most
of the time and to see him like actually
look like he's having a great time just
made
yeah to see him like bantering with the
interviewer because I liked her too like
I was like I'm gonna keep an eye out for
your show I think she did an interview
with the rock that I saw that was really
funny she's a funny ass woman I think I
see their chemistry together Ryan
Gosling and Ford just gets me excited I
see Blade Runner 2049 even more dirty
grandpa to man right they're gonna get
that one right keep a lookout for a
Blade Runner 2049 review it'll
definitely be up for most likely by
Saturday and yeah then shoot us your
star dust reactions and stuff if you
want to be in that video maybe you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can click that notification bellow
follow dat John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram
I'm at the greg alba take care